as this escalation of this proxy war
against Russia is going on and sending
tens of billions of dollars to Ukraine
not a single Democrat not even those who
claim to be the so-called Progressive
Champions voted against that funding it
was Republicans in the house and the
Senate who were the sole opposing voices
or even those just saying hey let's
answer the basic questions about what is
our objective what are we trying to
accomplish let's let's make sure we know
if we're sending money to go fund this
war where is that money going and how
can we be held to account for those
taxpayer dollars to our voters none of
that was allowed to happen and the
questions that were being asked were
coming from Republicans are you worried
that we're barreling into a nuclear
conflict deeply concerned you think
that's a plausible thing to worry about
I think that is exactly where we are and
we should all be concerned about that we
should all be demanding answers and
action from leaders people in Congress
and the Biden administration of why they
have allowed us to get to this point